from daytona international speedway this
is the motor racing this sport will
break you if you wait
i've noticed some faces like they're
surprised to see me
historically nascar is caucasian males
that's what people think of and that's
what they see in the sport
nobody at the track looks like me
my name is brianna daniels and i'm the
first african-american female pit crew
member for nascar
i had no idea that that would happen
that's not why i came to the sport
but i made history i'm still in shock
till this day
i was the only girl but it actually kind
of gave me some more motivation you know
to kick the guys butts i was going
against
i have to work twice as hard as the next
man does it's like i already have like
two targets on my back i'm a female i'm
african-american
everything i get i worked for
pit stops usually range between like 10
and 14 seconds
everybody has to move quick
there's a front tire changer a front
tire carrier a rear tire carrier a gas
man and a jack man and i am a rear tire
changer
we train year round because you have to
have that strength
this isn't just about car mechanics you
have to be an athlete
you know we're really in charge of
hooking that driver up and making sure
he's good to go our pit stop has to be
on point everybody has to come together
and work as one team to send our driver
off and have them in good hands
my mission is to make sure to be that
face for women of color and little boys
and little girls
and i hope that one day you know people
think of nascar they see it as multiple
faces and not just one
i want everybody to join the sport come
on
[Music]